[Musique]
festival a battu des records pour sa
quatrième édition à Mantes-la-Jolie avec
plus de 5000 entrées l'événement qui se
déroulaient sur trois jours à
l'Île-aux-Moines a su conquérir son
public j'adore l'ambiance je trouve
qu'il y a beaucoup d'animations il y a
plein de choses pour ce restaurer pour
aller boire un coup et surtout il y a
une section qui est gratuite donc c'est
bien pour les gens qui ont pas forcément
l'argent pour sécher une place ça permet
que tout le monde puisse venir et
s'amuser en général il y a quand même
pas mal de festivals sûrement donc c'est
une bonne chose c'est pas mal enfin puis
ça fait un bosser un peu le coin il y a
du bénévolat et tout c'est bien on est
avec les copains on sort une sortie à la
fraise et puis ça a l'air sympa donc
la musique est tellement bien éclectique
nous avons entendu qu'un artiste allait
venir nous nous sommes dit peut-être
qu'il jouera pas loin de Paris et il a
joué dans ce festival oui c'est vraiment
bien et très cosy un festival qui
souhaite valoriser le territoire mentois
notamment en mettant en avant les
saxophones c'est le maire et les
clarinettes des crampons fabriqués à
Mantes-la-Ville depuis la 19ème siècle
il y a des facteurs d'instruments et
aussi des accessoires risques enfin des
gens qui fabriquent et qui participent à
la fabrication de tout ce qui est autour
les instruments à vent des cuivres des
bois je viens faire découvrir le métier
Selmer en général qui est là depuis
plus d'abri des saxophones et déclare
net les gens sont très intéressés
comment on fait l'instrument comment il
est monté fini pour que le musicien
puisse jouer avec André Manoukian Michel
Jonas ou encore des luxe au total 20
concerts se sont déroulés sur 3 scènes
différentes un festival qui se distingue
par sa programmation éclectique vendredi
c'est au sein de c'était une thématique
autour de la musique du Levant de la
musique de l'Est de l'Europe et hier
c'était autour de la chanson française
et les instruments avant et là ce
dimanche nous valorisons l'ensemble du
groove dans les instruments avant avec
une journée destinée spécialement
famille c'est sur les notes funky et
grovis du groupe Deluxe que le festival
s'est achevé le dimanche le rendez-vous
est déjà pris pour la 5e édition en 2023
[Musique]